As it turns out there's
a flaw in our elegant system.
There are times when a hash function
will spit out the same hash value for
two different inputs.
This situation is termed a Collision.
There are two main ways
to fix a collision.
The first is to change the value
in your hash function, or
to change the hash function completely,
so
you have more than enough slots to
store all of your potential values.
You can also keep your
original hash function but
change the structure of your array.
Instead of storing one
hash value in each slot,
you can store some type of lists that
contains all values hashed at that spot.
These lists are generally
called buckets in this context.
Rather than storing one value in each
slot, you can store multiple values or
a collection in each bucket, but
are either of these
approaches actually helpful?
For the first one, you can
maintain constant time look up but
by using a bigger number
in your hash function,
you're going to require a lot
more space to store your values.
Also, if you do this reactively and
change the value in your hash function
every time you have a collision, moving
all of your data to a new array is going
to definitely increase the complexity
in terms of both size and time.
With the bucket approach, you still
need to iterate through some collection,
though a shorter one,
every time you're looking for something.
Hash functions have a constant
lookup time in the average case, but
because of the bucket system, you could
end up storing every value in one bucket
and then you're still essentially
just iterating through a list.
In that worse case,
this actually turns into O(m).
When done well,
hashing is really fast and
can save you a ton of time, but all of
these things are very real concerns.
There's no one perfect way
to design a hash function.
You need to consider
all of these things and
build a system that makes the most sense
for your data and your limitations.
Often, you'll have to choose between
making a hash function that spreads out
your values nicely but uses a lot of
space and one that uses less buckets but
might have to do some
searching within each bucket.
Ideally, you would have one to three
elements stored in each bucket.
So you can design a hash
function with that in mind.
You can also do something creative
like using a second hash function
inside of a large bucket to split
up those elements even more.
That would work particularly well if
you know you're going to have well
spread out data but end up having
a few really large buckets.
Hashing questions are popular because
there's often not a perfect solution.
You're expected to talk
about the upsides and
the downsides of whatever
approach you choose to use.
So, just do your best to
optimize your hash function and
make sure you're communicating
with your interviewer well.